I'm a little intimidated first of all by
this big very unknown I know is
wonderous look at it were you the first
time you came you saw one of these Jets
and you knew you kinda had to work with
a beast like this were you intimidated
at all and what does it feel like being
back in this realm again well luckily I
was able to fly in one before we shot oh
yeah then f-16 me Bree and Anna actually
and was able to fall six foot nine
cheese okay yeah it was it was the best
experience it really had to make you
feel like the ultimate badass for real
Oh surely fully one of those moments in
the movie where I'm like able to channel
that I just flip back to that and now
that really happens it really happens
for two amazing women who are fire
pilots and you know mums and wives and
all the things that Squatch well it
makes so much sense that we're back here
now yes to do this yeah um that feeling
and I know you said it makes you feel
like a badass but can you describe that
feeling the first time you get in the
seat of one of these Jets um well
firstly there's not everywhere that's
kind of like you just don't really want
to touch anything just in case like
you're moving all under control she's
like talking to you through the cones
like everything I cannot I don't know I
don't know what I need to do should
everything happen but it just feels like
power yeah it feels like complete
control like you know exactly what
you're doing and it's almost like you
were made for this yeah do you know I
mean so yeah it set me up completely for
this character man it just really threw
me into the world well in that it speaks
to the film because what we see in it
and what is mirrored which thank you
Jesus is women empower women doing the
most you know in it well and I love that
because Captain Marvel is arguably the
most powerful person in the Marvel
Universe yeah and so for you then what
makes brie Larson so perfect to be the
most powerful person in the mark
while she is a powerful person very
literally breeze a powerful person and
very she brings a very unique twist to a
superhero because she brings a human
element she was a sarcastic element
she's kind of like all the woman's all
around so we don't just see the powers
of a superhero we see the power of the
woman in every facet she shows exactly
how you need to feel to be enough in
this world and she does it beautifully
so I think that's one of the greatest
themes of this this movie women will
watch this and feel I'm enough I can be
enough because they showed me exactly
how I need to okay goose bump moment
number one of this interview there were
a couple times in the movie she had a
couple lines that I was like oh I am
woman hear me roar I think she said once
about I've always fought with one hand
yeah I know
I know there's so many lines in the so
many moments in this movie that make you
think I'm gonna be in so controlling
myself when I watch this man I'm gonna
step out of this cinema and just be have
a spring my step and just go back to
work and just do all the paperwork and
just stay up all night and just be on
top Jeanette Lee yeah you feel like
you're just ready for life what makes
you feel empowered through this movie
yeah well through this movie and I guess
just in life because this movie is about
empowered and powerful women in a lot of
ways I feel empowered when I don't have
to prove myself to anyone that was
another line of hers yeah honestly feel
like when I just stand my ground and
actually say no to a lot of things when
I just refuse because I want to even if
I go out and there's a lot of people
there and I chose to be there if I feel
in the moment not I want to be here I
will leave because I feel empowered
enough to say nut Oprah Winfrey just
said to me two weeks ago yeah no is a
complete sentence I don't have to think
note and lips this because should never
have to explain myself it's no because
I've decided from my true authentic self
that I don't want to so I could yes I
stand by Oprah for the rest of my life
now having said that I'm going to ask
you to explain yourself oh okay there
are gonna be people that go to this
movie and they're gonna be like oh I
like her I like her so much
who has leshawna which if you could give
me like three words to describe or three
things about you that people want to
know oh three things um that I come from
good stock come from a long line of
women who were in charge of themselves
and are in control of their lives who
worked out and my grandmother's from the
Windrush generation in London so she
came they came over from Jamaica and
just made it work so I naturally as an
individual now to make it work um I'm
the creator of all in all facets so I
like to create different ways whether it
be writing or directing acting so I like
to stick all my fingers in different
pies and I also like to make people
laugh I love that are you ready for the
Marvel moment I mean you are now in this
family you are now in the Marvel
Universe are you ready for that as ready
as I can because I know what a filly
entails yeah I have a couple of friends
who have been in Marvel movies and
they've spoken monies that have been in
them um so Daniel and someone who is
going to be in something soon so yes I
would say right now could there be
someone standing next to me that could
also be in something soon yes Oh meet
each other I honestly don't know I don't
know what kind of Marvel training y'all
get but it's the best time the absolute
but the finest of gold in the world I
honestly don't know we'll see
[Music]